What the fuck was that?!
Th-th-th AHFUCKING
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
And welcome to "The Wendigo"
Now if you remember "Until Dawn" there was a- uh
Oh hey. Strange creature surrounding mansion further research are to see. Our team decided to head out and investigate, great idea, upon arriving we split up
Great. Yeah, they're all dead going into the house is probably a bad idea
Yeah, a bad idea. I'm assuming, that's not a good thing. They all dead oh, I'm here
Oh ok
That's a strange glowing. Where am I.. ho, ah I'm in the house already. I did not know this
Hello ? Aah
Yes, oh-oh-oh good.
So if you remember in "Until dawn" there was such a creature called
the Wendigo, and all the people turned into
Pick up the Emf detector by using the E key
*dramatic music*
I don't like that tutorial image that you use. Why is there a doll staring at me that's bad!
Alright fine, then collect 10 recorders, hold Q to use EMF...
detector and escape the house I
I don't know if any of this is gonna be good, here we go
Alright, so I don't know how this game goes
But it's actually a pretty highly rated game on Steam so I can only assume that it's got some spooks... ready for me.
Oh
Ah this room is vacant of spooks. I've got to find something else though
Hmm seems to be a lot of things and stuff
Places for monsters to jump out at me
Which I don't like... for the record
But the Wendigo in Until dawn anyway was just this creature that appeared
Huh?
well now.. huh..
when uh..
Humans ate other humans in the place here. Oh, that's a camera
Oh, I probably should have scouted the cameras before I actually started going into the house. That was my mistake here
Okay, alrighty then... oh
Why am I looking for tape recorders? Why do I care so much ? ugh.. Am i cooOOHHEY
Heeeeeeey- HEEEEEEEEYY *continues screaming*
Hi.
I'm guessing I'm gon' find some ENF ratings in here. Oh
Oh, those are great pictures on the waaalls
Oh.. HEY STOP STARING AT MEH
FUCK YOU Okay I found one. K, good. Pickup
*tape playing*
*confused Mark*
OH HEY
OH FUCK YOU MAN FUCK YOU
Okay, alright, then good tape re-oh God. I've got an EMF. I got an EMF
Okay, alright. I was picking up some serious EMF readings up there, I don't wanna go back up
eh fuck
Hello, hi, how are you doing ? Is everybody- fuck off
okay.. all right, so I'm assuming that there's a wendigo in- HEYYY
Yeah, what what what you're doing oh FUCKING GOD DAMMIT NOOOOO
Fucking what the fuck was that ?..Is it the OH FUCKING GODAMMIT
*wendigo noises*
Oh. I'm dead I died at 9:14
Great I found one item and long in the short of it. I did God-awful
Fuck that thing
Jesus
Grumble in my ear. I know you like to  purr away, but no, thank you
All right here we go
Back into the thing oh man interacting with doors is a bit of pain. so can I see anything here?
Is there anything that's gonna help me
No
Maybe I could see the monster on this thing
No, ok
So here we go again. It's like... It's like Slender, but
worse
In every way !
I can't run fast. I outta be quick and skidaddley about it, but I'm not ready to
Alright so let me go back up to the kids room, that seemed to work well for me. I guess
kidding.. FUCKING FUCK YOU
I'm gonna go back because apparently I didn't pick up the goddamn reader. Cause I'm an idiot
Why can't I-I-I got got got it why can't I use it ?
*click click click click click click*
I'm pressing the button
*tape plays "one two one two"*
*"testing, one two three"*
*"Is this on mate?"*
*"It doesn't seem to be working"*
It's working all right
Yeah, what was that?
Maybe you should get the fuck out of there, and maybe I'm gonna die because I dont have a god damn radar!
I'm gonna go the ways that I haven't gone yet because apparently the kid is being a little douchebag
Ka-chunk right in my crotch
*tape plays*
OH..OOOOOOOH
NOOOOOOO
NONONONONONONO
Little little little run faster would be great
This son of a bitch hope he can't go upstairs. Yep, okay, open that in a quick flash
Ookay, why can't I use my goddamn EMF reading?
It's what I'm supposed to do
Oh fuck it's there, really, that's where it is?
*tape plays*
*Mark's strange noise*
I saw it. I saw it in the shadows down the way. I saw it. Oh boy. I saw it. Kid are you in here?
Okay, nevermind then, let's carry oON
Yes
*tape plays*
Ya Ive heard that already
shit shit shit- Oh shitty dicks
Don't come in here
Don't come in here you son of a bitch. Don't come in here
I'll punch the shit out of you in every way
every one of your bones is gonna get cried on
You know you don't want to mess with Markiplier
Yeah, I'm gonna be okay, maybe.. I just got to find a few more I'm actually not that far from it
oh HE-HEYYY NO
Yes, don't whisper in me whoo fuck
Okay, so I just got to go up the other staircase and then I should be okay if I go the back way
I might be able to get around this damn thing
Oh, God hole in the floor. Can I jump down ? great that did me a lot of good. fuck why did I go down?
It'll be okay..  Ah there we go
*tape plays*
They seem to be..
They're dead. Yeah, they're dead
seems like the tapes are just appearing in random locals strewing about the house
seems Like I
And then a lot of trouble! The fuck I heard thumps. sorry that's me..
Hi, okay. Alrighty, then we.. okay. Go down. Go down. What the fuck is that ? Okay ?
Don't do that.
Don't do that to me Ok we're fine everything's fine. Everything's goddamn fire
Everything is hunky-dordy dordy dordy everything is hunky-dory in lala land
I don't know how many I've got left to find but it can't be too many
I mean it could be whole lot however many they want..
*scream*
No that was bad hallway. I got some sensory feelings about that one
Fuck
YOUUU.. I saw that
Goddammit fuck gfgkh I skedaddle as hard as I can
I got my SKEDADDLE JUICE
Fuck I'm not going to get that right now I'm gonna get later
GAAH I've got an appointment
*dies* Fuck
*sexy look at the cam*
Well shit
And that's a sack of tits. Oh there it is, got it nailed it. Give give give give GIVE TO MEEE
Just give it to me
*tape plays + focused Mark*
Yeah I get that okay
Stippy stepy..
What does that mean ?! wait there's a problem HERE? Oh there's problem run fastly.
Jesumps
So you have to hit shift, you can't just hold shift down. You got to hit it to run
Shit, shit dicks, okay, that makes sense.. I guess
Wo.. wowowo..
I don't like that
huh waaaheyyoh
Yeahy yeaah
Yeti, Wendigoohohoh
AH Fucking GO GO GO GO GO GOO-ah fu-I'm dead i'm dead a million ways. I'm dead. I'm dead
OOoooOOwoow
I'm trying to skedaddle. My skedaddle button is a little broken. trying to Skedaddle. Oh..
Skedaddly no Skedaddle
I think I got away I guess ?
I don't know how, I don't know why, I think I did and that's good. I guess
*strange mouth movements*
Tape- "What the heck was that?" *wendigo screams* "No no no" *with poor acting*
No, no, no uh, I've been eating, ughs, they didn't belieeve
Cuz it didn't believe.. okay, so where is he ?.. I should- oh I see him. He's in.. where the fuck is that ?
But I see a red dot of there. Oh so I can see..
Alright..
So he's over there, that's the second bedroom. So that's where he is right now
So if I can look for a red, oh, oh wait WAIT OH you LIED to me
They lied to me, you lied, to me, it lied to me. Oh shit this is a bad idea
Hum hu-hu-huhuum *motocycle sounds ?*
*scared face*
everythings fine..
That's bad.. *weird sounds*
so he's getting a lot more active,
That's exactly- OH fucking fuck fucking fucking fuck, fuuuuck you. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead
I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm trying. I'm spamming the run button
Hm hm hm
7 of 10, almost there !
Yeah, I get that. Why do I need the rep- OOooh hey hey hey Whoa? What the fuck was that ?
OOooh no thank you no thank you no thank you no thank you no thank you ooooh no thank you
Rawr Rawr Rawr rawr rawr rawr... no, no no
Aaaw fu-fucking what the fuck
Why do I need this I could just go away
I could just go home at any moment that be fun and fine and cool- oooh that's fucking bullshit
Fuck you, man
Fuck oaaaf
Can't find these goddamn things.. Where is it ? oh God damn it here can I get this axe?
Yeah its hunted all right? Yeah, fuck. I'm dead. I think I saw it behind me, but I don't think that's gonna help me (for sure)
Fuck fuck. Go, go go fucking gooo
FUCKING GO
Okay, we're you at ?  Do I- OOOH What the fuck?
That's not fair. That's not fair. That's not fair. not fair
Not fair not fair not fair nothing not fair not fair not fair
This fucking run system is not fair
not fair not fair not fair nooot fair *too much "not fair"* not fair not fair not fair..
OOOH NOT FAIR NOT FUCKING FAIR
Okay..so anyway that is, Wendigo. I'm not gonna do that again cuz that is..
That is the opposite of fair so I found 8 of 10, I don't know what happens when you get all 10
I'm assuming there's something along like.. "hey. you won. Good job"
Go get an ice cream or something like that." So let me know what you think of this, if you want play for yourself
It's available on Steam right now, and my voice needs a little bit of a break
but thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought of it down the comments below
And as always, I will see you...
In the next video. Bye bye !
*outro discorded music as the camera zooms on the dool*